cela fait maintenant plus d'un mois et
demi que des millions de français sont
confinés chez eux un confinement pour
qui pour les personnes atteintes de
troubles mentaux représentent un
véritable parcours du combattant cela
concernerait 12 millions de français
reportage de la neige à tarassac fabrice
68 ans qui est atteint de psychose
depuis l'installation du confinement il
n'est plus en mesure de se déplacer pour
se rendre à ces rendez vous médicaux
cloîtré s'isoler chez mise à l'écart il
essaie de passer le temps comme ils le
peuvent
j'avais un studio la ola il est tout
petit et j'ai 22 mètres carrés et jeu je
me dis je ne sais vue entre la lecture
regarder la télévision ou me reposer une
sieste et je lis des livres que j'avais
pas encore lu j'ai fait un tour au métro
poissonnière et je remonte je descends
reds remontent et ça fait des grosses
via les jambes et en l'air à peu je dois
beaucoup de gens évidemment mais c'est
un mas c'est un pis aller par rapport à
ce qu'on faisait avant c'est qu'on se
voyait beaucoup entre amis coin un
quotidien transformer si un accès aux
soins limité l'anxiété créé par le
confinement un impact plus important sur
les personnes souffrant de troubles
mentaux et peut même provoquer des mises
en danger il ya des formes de pour des
compensations qu'ils peuvent
trop violente le fait qu'au soir du plô
confinant le clan c'est que par soi les
deux livres à rechercher un objet d'une
station cet objet de fixation ça peut
être l'enfant qui à ce moment là se
retrouvent le récepteur de tous les
délits le confinement un facteur de
risque psychique pour tous
la distanciation social peut en effet
provoquer des signes de détresse
psychologique
il suffit d'un traumatisme nouveau dans
sa vie et ça peut être le confinement
pour que se révèlent des états
dépressifs ou des états anxieux faut une
attention particulière à la santé
mentale poser des mots dire les choses
dire que le confinement est difficile
est une épreuve essayer de mettre des
liens autres comme on le fait tous avec
le télétravail c'est pareil pour ces
personnes il faut essayer de communiquer
via les réseaux sociaux maintenir des
liens avec l'extérieur
une situation qui pourrait ne pas
s'arranger au 11 mai date de la fin du
confinement et pour cause le
gouvernement appelle à favoriser le
télétravail autant que possible après
cette date